مشاهدينا ننتقل الى ما يحدث داخل القرم
وهناك روسيا تمنع اطفالا من العوده الى
منازلهم بعد ان امضوا وقتا في مخيم صيفي
في شبه جزيره القرم هذا ما افادت به صحيفه
ديكارديان التي نقلت معلومات عن هؤلاء
الذين ما زالوا محتجزين هناك ويبلغوا
عددهم من الطفل على الاقل في حديثها
للصحيفه البريطانيه قالت ناديه طبعا ناديه
هي ام اوكرانيه مقيمه بمدينه خرسون قالت
انها لم ترى ابنها البالغ من العمر 14
عاما منذ اكثر من شهرين بعد ما ارسلته
لمخيم كان من المفترض ان ينقذ فيه لمده
اسبوعين فقط فبالنسبه لها وكالعديد من
الاباء في اخرصون تعتبر نادي هذا المخيم
في القرم وجهها صيفيه رائعه للاطفال كونه
يطل على البحر ولكن الان تم منعه ابنها من
العوده الى خيصون والسبب سياسي
حسبون تحررت مؤخرا على يد القوات
الاخرانيه في نوفمبر ولكن بالنسبه
ما زالت تابعه لها تقول روسيا ان سبب
منعها الاطفال من العوده الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه التي كانت تسيطر عليها موسكو
هو من اجل سلامتهم لكن لمنظمات حقوق
الانسان الاوكرانيه راي اخر يشير الى ان
هذه المخيمات الصيفيه تستخدم لاعاده توجيه
الاجيال القادمه بقصد محو الهويه
الاوكرانيه وفقا لديكارديا تزعم السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في القرن انها انفقت 19
مليون دولار في عام 20 22 على معسكرات
الاطفال والتي تم الترويج لها عبر المدارس
في المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا سابقا
على انها تقدم مزيجا من الترفيه
والرياضيات والفنون